uh good afternoon welcome to ee 380 this
is a stanford university's
symposium on computer systems
our speaker today is peter mcmahon he's
going to speak about computing with
physical systems he's a professor at
cornell university and
spent
his graduate years at stanford uh in any
case uh
peter it's all yours
great well thank you very much for the
invitation to speak uh and thanks for
the the kind introduction
uh
ee 380 was actually the very first class
i took at stanford it was in
fall of 2008 and i remember sitting in
there in the room and gates where the
seminars took place and filling in the
uh the weekly homework of summarizing
what the speaker said um so it's very
fun fun to be back and uh even though
it's only virtual i hope that i i get to
come back in person at some point in the
not too distant future i'm sure i will
but nevertheless it's great to have the
opportunity to share this work with the
with everyone here virtually today um
and uh
the as the title of the slide says i'm
going to talk about computing with
physical systems
and
uh maybe slightly
uh to give a slight more hint of kind of
what this is going to entail is i'm
going to talk about how we can try to
harness
physical systems that have complex
dynamics and use the intrinsic computing
that those systems naturally do to do
useful things for us and in particular
we're going to
try to train them to act as neural
networks
before i get ahead of myself though i'm
really just here to do the advertising
the the actual work is of course done by
the members of my group
uh and i've listed
at least most of the members here and uh
the funding for this work primarily
comes from ntt and the nsf but
later on in the talk i will highlight a
couple of
members whose work that i'm really
focusing on today
so the the grand plan is first of all i
think for this audience i probably don't
need to go into great detail about
exactly what neural networks are but i
wanted to at least set the nomenclature
as that we're all on the same page about
what particular terms mean so i'll
quickly go through about what neural
networks are
and in particular why and how we might
want to improve their energy efficiency
for inference
then the
meat of the talk is really going to be
this middle part here of this discussion
of physical neural networks of how we
can build neural networks out of
essentially arbitrary physical systems
there will be some caveats on the
arbitrary but
to first order
how you can use arbitrary physical
systems to do neural network computing
for us
and then once i've shown you how we've
done this and the demonstrations that
we've performed so far i'll talk a
little bit about future directions that
hopefully some of them appeal to a
computer systems audience so maybe one
of the main future directions that one
can i can think of building off the
narrative that we
will set up
the the first parts of the talk is how
we can potentially build machine
learning accelerators
and this is something that i think
connects very well with several previous
speakers uh already at least in calendar
2022 i was watching some of the ee 380
youtube recordings last night and saw
some nice talks from grok and others
on work that's happening with cmos
devices that are machine learning
accelerators and i'll talk a little bit
about the prospects for trying to build
physical systems that are much more
exotic than cmos that might be able to
compete
i'll also talk about smart sensors which
i think is a perhaps much more near-term
direction of how you can do machine
learning within a
sensing device uh this is maybe a little
abstract but i'll i'll go into some
detail that will hopefully make it clear
i'll talk a bit about an extension of
this work to a potential extension of
this work to quantum systems
and also talk about something a little
more general if we figured out how to
make neural networks out of arbitrary
physical systems but it turns out that
we've essentially figured out a way to
make arbitrary physical systems perform
functions for us and this might be
useful for other things besides neural
networks so i'll also talk about that
so let's uh let's dive in so first of
all i wanted to really briefly emphasize
the difference between inference and
training in neural networks and the
reason for this is that
we're going to be focusing on inference
in this talk it's not because i don't
believe training is important
or because we don't have
work trying to
improve training but
the focus of the work that i'm going to
tell you about today is really on
inference so just as a quick reminder
inference is essentially this task of
given some trained machine learning
model and for example an image of a
handwritten digit uh make a prediction
of what that image is you get given this
image and it makes a prediction that
that was an eight
this is as opposed to training where in
training you are given some
labeled data set
uh for example we told these are all
examples of zeros and these are all
examples of ones etc and given this
label data set of handwritten images
produce a trained model
and then that trained model is the thing
that gets used during inference
so we're going to focus on inference and
the reason that this is sensible
is that in these cloud settings
inference costs can dominate
it could be 80 to 90 percent of the
total dollar or energy cost of
performing machine learning and
intuitively this is because you can
imagine some small engineering team
maybe uses a compute cluster of
reasonable size to train some model but
then once they finish training it they
deploy it to the cloud and it can get
used by
tens or even hundreds of millions of
people if you think of something like
google translate for example
and uh this is not a number i just
pulled from nowhere this number of 80 to
90 comes from a number of sources
including amazon and their introduction
of their inference targeted
chips a couple of years ago
also from nvidia also from mckenzie etc
also just to
sort of set the set the nomenclature not
because i expect the so this audience
doesn't know about neural networks but
just to make sure we're all on the same
page with kind of what term what terms
i'm using
uh a quick review of neural networks in
particular so again if we're trying to
do handwritten
handwritten digit inference we're trying
to go from this input image to a
prediction that this was an eight and
the most canonical straightforward
diagram of a neural network doing this
would be a multi-layer perceptron that's
depicted here where you have multiple
layers in the neural network that are
each depicted by the set of circles
which are the neurons
and you can think about the information
propagating through this neural network
as being realized by matrix vector
multiplications where you have a vector
representing each layer and then a
matrix vector multiplication
causes the information to propagate from
one layer to the next and after this
linear operation of matrix vector
multiplication you apply element-wise
non-linearity at each neuron this is the
most canonical form of a neural network
which would be good enough for our
purposes
so now there are many different academic
and commercial groups trying to build
accelerators for
neural networks and accelerators is
sometimes a misnomer because often
they're not trying to make the inference
task
happen faster
but they're trying to make it happen
more energy efficiently although
sometimes it's also faster but
in general the main goal is typically to
try and make inference more energy
efficient
and there are essentially two
philosophies about how you can go about
trying to make it a hardware accelerator
for for neural networks you can either
go for an exact mathematical equivalence
with the mathematical description of a
neural network i just gave or you can go
for what i might call an approximate
mathematical equivalence there's an
asterisk here that i'll explain shortly
so
concretely a little bit more concrete
what i really mean by this well again
this is this description of the
mathematical description of a canonical
multi-teptron
where the workhorse here is a matrix
vector multiplication and
this even in more complicated neural
network architectures typically the
matrix vector multiplications or vector
vector dot products are the the most uh
compute intensive part of the the neural
network inference
so an accelerator that has an exact
equivalence the goal is to try construct
a piece of hardware that will exactly
implement matrix vector multiplication
where you give it a matrix you give it a
vector and it does that
and
the benefit of building such an
accelerator is that
now you can use this hardware as
essentially a drop-in replacement for a
model that was trained on a cpu or a gpu
or a tpu or any other kind of
asic
that were
for neumann computing device that was
trained under the assumption that you
had matrix vector multiplications to
propagate your information
the disadvantage is that making a system
that performs matrix vector
multiplication is
it's a very specific type of operation
that you're asking it to do and so
a physical system doesn't naturally just
do matrix-vector multiplications you
have to really carefully engineer a
device to do this and there are people
building all sorts of interesting
devices including photonic neural
networks and memories to crossbar arrays
as well as kind of more conventional
cmos
devices
but all of them have this con that
because you're insisting that it exactly
does a matrix vector multiplication
you have to leave some energy
you have to use some extra energy and
some extra engineering effort to achieve
that and a tall alternative is let's
make some hardware that doesn't exactly
do this it does something like this
but not exactly
and
the big pro of making something that has
this sort of approximate equivalence for
the mathematical operation shown here is
that now you can make the hardware maybe
a little more sloppy
and it can be more energy efficient
because you are forcing it to do
something that didn't exactly want to do
to begin with
the big disadvantage of uh building some
accelerator that only has an approximate
mathematical equivalence though is that
now you need to retrain your machining
learning model every time
uh you want to use this hardware because
you can't just take a model that was
trained assuming this operation is the
thing it does and actually does
something different
so there's a trade-off but uh we're
interested in well we're my group is
interested in both parts of this
trade-off but the work i'll tell you
about today is more in the sort of
second category here
and the catch or the the asterix is
really about i set up this dichotomy
between exact and approximate
equivalence um
but really it's even more extreme than
that we don't have to even go for an
approximate equivalence we it turns out
that we can really even just make
hardware accelerators that do an
operation that's kind of vaguely
inspired by what happens in this
canonical form
but again i'll i'll dive into
this much more deeply in the next
section and show you some concrete
examples of this but this is what we're
about we're trying to build
hardware accelerators for machine
learning or at least one way of framing
our work as
or targets of our work is to try build
hardware accelerators for machine
learning where we have only an
approximate or sort of very vaguely
inspired connection with the canonical
mathematics but we still want to try and
see if this works
so this uh this work we call physical
neural networks because we're going to
try to build neural networks out of
physical systems and this work was led
by two postdocs in my group logan wright
and tatsuhiro onodera and they were ably
assisted by phd student martin stein
so again the goal is to try
build some hardware that will perform
the inference task in neural networks
very energy efficiently
and
the intuition and the promise of trying
to build neural networks out of physical
systems is that many physical systems
are very expensive in energy and in time
to try a simulator on a digital computer
this is because they exhibit some
complex behavior so they're
intrinsically doing a lot of computing
and a
very canonical example of this would be
a wind tunnel if you have
some car or some airplane design
and
you want to check how well it works you
could do a simulation on a cluster of
gpus that takes
minutes or hours or days depending on
how high the resolution or accuracy you
want is
or
you could take that bottle car or
airplane design and put it into a wind
tunnel turn the wind on and one second
later you will have the full
distribution of
pressures and velocity velocities
everywhere
so there's a strong sense in which a
wind tunnel is computing the navy stokes
equations very very energy efficiently
far more so than a digital computer
could
and so the
promise or the thought that we had from
this is well can you try to turn the
situation around say well if a wind
tunnel computes very is this this very
complicated thing very energy
efficiently can we somehow harness that
to use and use that physical system to
perform expensive computations for us
besides just acting as a wind tunnel
it's clear that it can act well as a
wind tunnel but cannot do some other
type of computation for us that's
essentially the uh
the intuition and this is very much uh
kind of copying feynman's intuition or
building on it for uh or adapting it to
classical systems where feynman
motivated the development of quantum
computers by saying the quantum systems
are very difficult to simulate on
classical computers so why don't we
build a computer out of quantum systems
and then it should be more powerful than
what we have available classically
uh and we are making essentially the
exact same argument
except we're saying well it doesn't even
have to be a quantum system it's
difficult to simulate with a digital
computer many classical physical systems
are also difficult
the big challenge then is how do we take
some arbitrary physical system that has
some complex dynamics and make it behave
as a neural network when it
is some physical system that could be
pretty arbitrary like a wind tunnel it
doesn't naturally look like a a neural
network so that's really the the
challenge we set for ourselves so we're
not going to try to
arbitrary computations uh we're not
going to try kind of make microsoft
excel or whatever go faster we're really
going to specialize in neural networks
but still it's
less than obvious kind of how one would
really go about doing this
so
the way that we approach this is the
following so here at the bottom is a
diagram that is a slightly different
drawing of something that's very
standard in machine learning this is a
depiction of a
several layer deep neural network for
classifying a handwritten nate
and the the diagram of the the neural
network is just a little different than
we used to because now instead of
drawing circles for neurons at each
layer we're just going to have these
gray boxes and each gray box represents
a layer in the deep neural network
and into each box
we have an input of data
and some trainable parameters
and in the case of a canonical
multi-layer perceptron this gray box
would be a matrix vector multiplication
using the parameters the parameters
would be the elements of the weight
matrix
and then
that would be followed by an element
wise non-linearity so multi-layer
perceptron in this diagram's way of
showing things would just be a matrix
vector multiplication and element-wise
non-linearity happening in each of these
gray boxes
and then eventually at the output of
this network the goal is well if you put
in an 8 you wanted to say well that was
an 8 with high probability
so the the twist that we
decided to test was
nobody said that these gray boxes had to
be matrix vector multiplications and
element wise non-linearities that's a
it's motivated for reasonably good
reason but it's in some sense a
historical accident of how artificial
neural networks were developed
so that they didn't have to have that
functional form so what happens if we do
something a little bit crazy
and
in the in the gray box
we put a physical system
that into the physical system we feed
some data and some parameters
and we let the physical system evolve
for some amount of time
and then we read out the state of the
system or some part of the state of the
system
and so we can in this way treat the
physical system as performing an input
output map or an implementation of a
function it takes these parameters and
this input data as inputs
and then it after some amount of time
produces some set of outputs
so in an abstract sense this physical
dynamical system can produce a
it can perform a function for you that's
some just some input output map
and we could use
that function inside these gray boxes
so just for this grey box we can replace
it with a physical system
that physical system could be anything
it could be some optical setup where we
have for example a non-linear optical
crystal and we shine laser pulses into
it and it converts the colors of them it
could be some mechanical system where
what's depicted here is a piece of metal
being shaken on a rod
it could be some electronic system but
that's not a digital cmos device but
some complex analog
non-linear dynamical system or
many other different kinds of physical
system anything in principle is possible
so our kind of concept was to replace
these block these layers and neural
network with physical systems and then
figure out a way to train the parameters
of the physical systems to see if they
could be trained to perform machine
learning tasks
so the the way we went about training is
that we had two key ideas the first is
that we really want to be able to use
back propagation and perform gradient
descent because this has proved to be
enormously successful in the
conventional deep learning community so
we wanted to be able to to leverage that
and in order to use back propagation
uh
the at least a natural way to do this is
to have a digital model of your physical
system
so that you can have a computer compute
the gradients with respect to the
function
so
the first key idea is we're going to use
a digital model as part of our training
and this is why i
emphasize at the start of the talk our
goal is going to be to try speed up the
inference we need to be able to train
the system but
the training will not necessarily
receive any benefit in the way we're
currently doing things here because
we're going to involve a digital
computer
then the second key idea
is that if we try to train everything on
a computer with the digital model
we'll find that you need to have an
extremely accurate digital model which
isn't really realistic for an analog
complicated physical system
and so we introduce a procedure that's
essentially a
it's named in homage to quantization
aware training uh for those of you from
the neural network community that will
be familiar uh it's also
has come up in various
more specialized guises before for
example chip in the loop training and so
on
which we call physics away training
where essentially the key idea is that
you do
the training not just with the digital
model you do a combination where you do
forward pass and hardware
and then you do the backward pass in the
digital model and this makes the system
robust to noise and imperfections in the
model in a way that i'll show now
so to give a single layer example of how
this works
we have
some piece of training data from the
training set and it's shown in red we
have some parameter choices the
parameters shown in orange this is fed
into a physical system the physical
system performs a function on this and
it gives some output
we can now feed that output into a
laptop and your laptop can identify
how wrong this output was knows what the
target was let's say if we're trying to
classify the handwritten digit as an
eight it should be
high at eight and lower everywhere else
and it wasn't quite there so it can say
okay well this part was overlapping with
eight but it's supposed to be higher and
everything else is supposed to be lower
so for that you can it can do a
subtraction and perform a compute an
error vector
and then this error vector can be
propagated backwards through the
differentiable digital model sitting on
the laptop
and and that
and this can be done with standard pi
torch automatic differentiation tools
and that will produce gradients so it'll
tell you how you should move these
parameters to try and reduce this error
and then you can update the parameters
and then go through the loop again send
through the physical system it'll
hopefully have a smaller error from the
target and kind of keep going and going
and going and so you trade in the loop
in the standard way
and
it turns out that this both works and
also isn't it and also is necessary uh
so
this uh plot here shows accuracy as a
function of the training epoch
and this was performed with a an
experimental setup
that used optics
and was training to perform
vowel spoken vowel classification so
some relatively simple machine learning
benchmark task what we see is that in
blue
as we go through the the training data
set and we go through training the
system we get better and better accuracy
and this is using our procedure that i
described here we do forward pass
positive physical system and backward
pass through the digital model
in contrast if you try to use the laptop
alone to do the training so you do the
forward pass through the digital model
and the backward pass through the
digital model which we call in silico
training
then you what you see is that when you
run on the actual hardware you get an
answer that's no better than random
guessing
so this showed that this procedure
really was necessary
so both works and is it's important to
do it this way that's because building
physical models that exactly capture
analog dynamics even for relatively
simple systems turns out to be pretty
hard
so let's now show
a few more examples
uh with a slightly more complicated task
so in this case
we're doing we're going to do
handwritten
digit recognition
and the first example that i'm showing
here is with a mechanical system that's
going to be implemented with three
layers
and the mechanical system that
exists within each of the gray boxes
is a piece of metal that's shown here
that's this gray square it's a piece of
titanium
that gets shaken by an audio speaker
and so the input to this layer is some
time domain voltage or current signal
being fed to the speaker and then the
output is a recording of a microphone
sitting above that metal plate
so this physical system
i hope it is clear
it was not a priori design to
perform handwritten digit classification
it seemingly has absolutely nothing to
do with image classification of any type
let alone human handwritten
classification it's literally just a
piece of metal on an audio speaker
and
we constructed this three-lane neural
network can use the p-80 training
procedure to try to
convince the system to classify
handwritten digits accurately
and what's shown at the bottom are the
results which is the confusion matrix of
what digit did we predict versus what
was the correct answer and if this was
performing with 100 accuracy you would
see every element along the diagonal
would be 100 and everything off diagonal
would be zero
so you see that
it doesn't perform perfectly
but it's getting many of the digits very
well some of them a little bit less well
like 73 percent here and overall the
accuracy was about 87 so certainly by
kind of standard machine learning
standards uh even from 20
plus years ago
this is a very bad mnist handwritten
digit classifier
still
it was a shaken piece of metal that did
this
that got 87 accuracy uh so that was this
is not intended as a well we're going to
replace gpus with shaken pieces of metal
uh i'll get to kind of how we how we
might think about trying to to leverage
this to to compete against standard cmos
and neural network accelerators
this was meant more as a demonstration
that a really obscure piece of physical
hardware can actually perform
a pretty standard machine learning task
we did the same thing with an electronic
system but not
a cpu or a gpu or even a cpu from 30 or
40 or 50 years ago an extremely simple
circuit so this circuit is shown here
and the breadboard the circuit diagram
is here it's an rlc circuit so an rlc
oscillator with one transistor added in
and the purpose of the added transistor
is to provide non-linearity because an
rlc circuit is at least an idealized
case linear and we know from the
standard machine learning literature
that
non-linearity is extremely important in
neural networks
but this is a very simple circuit by
computer standards and you can see that
from the photograph this was constructed
in my postdoc logan's apartment during
the pandemic lockdown this is uh i don't
think he will be offended if i say
it looks kind of like a middle
schooler's first attempt at a circuit
and it was purposefully so we did not
carefully engineer the circuit to do
machine learning we just built a very
simple circuit that was supposed to have
relatively complex time dynamics
and then we wanted to see if we could
use it to perform machine learning and
in this case it was again a three layer
neural network that was implemented uh
this time instead of just one copy of
the neural network logan made seven
copies of it
and then averaged the results
um
and
this uh this circuit has complex enough
dynamics this actually worked it's
achieved accuracy of a little bit over
90 percent
so it's actually surprisingly good
considering it's just got one transistor
and then a final example
is we use the nonlinear optical system
where it was a nonlinear optical crystal
that we shine pulses of laser light
through where the pulses are shortened
time so they're broad in frequency and
we encoded the parameters in the data in
the frequency domain or the wavelength
domain of the pulse
and then this crystal convert takes uh
pairs of photons and you can think about
them kind of mushing them together and
producing one single photon that is at
the sum of the energies of the two input
photons and so it performs a relatively
complex operation of uh of taking all
these different combinations of pairs of
photons and summing them together and
then producing a new
spectrum of color out so we have a
spectrum of light going in and a
spectrum of light that we can measure as
the output
and in this case we performed
two physical layers with this as well as
a digital layer on a laptop
and in this case we're able to achieve
97 accuracy on this endless handwritten
digit classification task
i'm going to pause briefly there so
dennis's video is turned on and i'm
curious if he has a question
no i'm just uh
playing
very good
um
incidentally if anyone has any questions
at any time please do feel free to
interrupt
so these three demonstrations are
demonstrations of the basic concept that
we can take very
not carefully designed for machine
learning physical systems and convert
them into things that actually perform
machine learning for us
uh how you feed the pictures actually
pixels here in that
models right yeah so
it's a great question so
how do we encode the image data into
these physical systems and i guess
simultaneously i can also answer how do
we put the parameters in
so
the input data is
you can think about it as a 2d image
it's just you can flatten it and it
becomes a 1d vector of numbers
and
in the case of
the optical system we fed the image in
conceptually as uh a part of the
frequency spectrum the frequency
spectrum is well the x-axis is
wavelength of frequency so it's a
one-dimensional thing and we can just
say well part of that spectrum uh is
where we're gonna take the flattened
eight
uh image and encode that into that part
of the spectrum
uh in the case of the electronics and
the mechanics uh both of them were done
very similarly is that you have some
time varying voltage or current waveform
and you can again take your flattened
image vector
you've made it into a 1d vector and then
you can feed it in as a voltage as a
function of time
so one more question about uh the
encoding so instead of flattening just
do it just down like pixel by pixel and
line by line or is it think uh or is it
using something like locality preserving
order or something more sophistic like
something more more even more
complicated
we tried a bunch of different things i
think in the end um
the the way things were done was with
patches
so there's some
notion of locality preserving maybe in
your nomenclature if we didn't just
go row by row
um because from kind of reasonable
intuition
it's more important to have the sort of
things that are spatially nearby within
2d then the stuff that's far apart in
one dimension
yeah thank you that makes sense
i think i missed something basic which
is how do you adjust adjust the
parameters given the error vector how do
you know which parameters to adjust and
how
sure
so the way that this works is through
this training procedure where we send
some data with some choice of parameters
through the physical system it computes
you now compute an error vector on a
laptop
and then this error vector gets
sent through a differentiable digital
model so we literally use the standard
machine learning
software pytorch to do this
and this uh
the pi torch uh different order
differentiation tool will compute the
gradients for us so we give it a model
of the system
uh that is differentiable we give it the
error vector and it will tell us the
gradient and then we can say okay let's
take the parameters we had and add the
gradient to it so that
we it's adjusted and then we feed it
back into the system again
what do you do in case of multi-layer
multiple layers right so this uh this
example here you're showing is just a
single layer
for essentially ease of illustration
purposes this naturally generalizes to
multiple layers though in
much the same way that
automatic differentiation training or
backprop training
extends to multiple layers in the case
of conventional
artificial neural networks
yes thank you
great thanks
so
a natural question one might ask after
seeing this is like well we shook a
metal plate and it banished we manage to
train it to classify 108
digits is why does this work why does
using a continuous time dynamical system
as the neural network work
why does replacing these grey block
boxes with physical systems function
and essentially i can give some
intuition that is inspiration from the
so-called neural ode literature which is
actually something that was
inspirational in the development of this
project in the first place so it's not a
explanation we came up with after the
fact that something that inspired us to
try to begin with
and there's a very very interesting
uh
essential state of results at this point
about
deep deep artificial neural networks
where for example you have something
like resnet
from 2015
where it achieved state-of-the-art
performance on imagenet
but it did so with a very deep network
and
a bunch of people got thinking about
this one of them was wine and e
uh
and
i think the the thought process was it's
kind of interesting that
if you take a d a
a few layer neural network and you make
it deeper it gets better and then you
make it deeper it gets better and then
you make it even deeper and it gets even
better
and then there's some catches of you
have to put skip connections in to deal
with vanishing gradients and so on but
to first order the message of deep
learning is that deeper is better
uh they looked at this
and said
this is kind of interesting that as you
go deeper and you add more and more
discreet steps
uh that things get better and better and
you know what that reminds one of that
reminds one of
uh dynamical systems and numerical
solving of odes or pdes where if you
discretize with some big time step and
you only have a few time steps you don't
get a very accurate answer but if you
make the time step smaller and smaller
and smaller you get more and more
accurate answers
and
the wine and e and others manage to show
that actually resnet you can model this
as a discretization
of a continuous time dynamical system
so there's a sense in which resonate is
really a discretization of something
that's underlying is actually continuous
and so this was very inspirational to us
because we said well if if that's true
then why instead of making a digital
system that discretizes it discretizes
everything in time why don't you build a
physical system that is continuous time
in the first place um and we didn't end
up
doing exactly that so this connection
between
discretization
of dynamical systems being what
some artificial neural networks at least
like resonate are and the actual
dynamical systems we use is just
intuition or inspiration
because we didn't actually make a
dynamical system that actually had
exactly this ode
but it shows an example at least of why
a continuous time dynamical system or a
way in which it can actually be in some
sense the same as a
as a conventional
state-of-the-art
deep neural network
so i think this is a really
nice connection that uh that has
both motivated us but it's also nice as
a make as some intuition for why this is
even
not a totally crazy thing to have have
had happened
that we can do it
endlessly
these three totally different dynamical
continuous time dynamical systems and it
actually works
so another
natural thing to wonder is okay these
three physical systems each of them were
pretty rudimentary the optics won less
so than the mechanics and the
electronics but what else might you try
to do this with and so we're very
interested in figuring out what are good
physical systems to do this with um and
you there are many people working on
neuromorphic computing with spintronic
nano oscillators for example and i think
this could be a very interesting
platform to try this with um similarly
there are many people thinking about
superconducting circuits in the
classical domain
and using those for neuromorphic
computing and we can imagine trying to
build physical neural networks out of
these you could also imagine somewhat
more exotic things if you take some
material system for example some 2d
material heterostructures and you have
you can
inject photons into them and make or you
can shine photons on them and generate
excitons and these exotics can have some
complex dynamics and you can imagine
trying to harness these complex dynamics
in a in a quantum material to
to perform machine learning for you and
it could really be any physical system
so i think
when i give this talk to applied physics
so physics audiences i really emphasize
if you have a physical system that's
hard to simulate on your laptop and you
would like to try turning it into a
neural network feel free to give it a
try we put our code on github or you're
welcome to contact us
so if it happens to be anybody who in
the audience today who's a physicist or
applied physicist who works with some
hard to simulate physical system and you
want to give this a go
please feel free to reach out but also
you can also just try it with the
open source code we put out
so
that is a
a kind of natural seg into well what are
some future directions besides well
let's try it with other different
physical systems and as physicists we
can certainly have fun with that but
what are some application directions for
this
so now i'm going to talk about a few in
the last
sort of ten or so minutes of
uh what are the ways or at least what
are the one way we can imagine building
uh large-scale optical accelerators or
accelerators using optics that might
eventually be competitors to cpus or
gpus or tpus as neural network inference
engines
i'll describe smart sensors which is a
catch-all phrase for devices where
you're trying to sense something about
the environment and you want to you do
some machine learning within the
hardware itself before you send it off
to a computer
i think it's a very interesting
extension of this work to quantum
systems
and then
there's something that's really not
connected with machine learning at all
but that we can try to leverage our
physics aware training procedure to let
physical devices be trained to perform
new functions
let's start off with the photonic neural
networks or optical neural networks and
uh there's a i'm personally very
interested in the prospect for optics to
be used to construct machines that can
outperform cmos electronics
at neural network inference i think it's
an extremely difficult goal because cmos
has had so many years of development and
so much money put into the development
but from a physics basis there is a
reason to believe that one could achieve
this and i think it's a very interesting
research topic
so in my own lab we've been working on
optical neural networks where we are
working in the spatial domain so we
encode vectors into beams of light that
we can fan out and make copies of we
then uh
perform
element-wise multiplications using
spatial light modulators and then uh
can
perform
essentially perform vector vector dot
products where uh the the sum and the
vector vector dot product happens by
just
multiple beams of light being collapsed
onto a single detector
and this is just one example of a
photonic neural network there are many
other approaches people are uh are
pursuing at the moment including both
commercially and in academia
uh but in our case one of the things
that we've recently worked on that i
think is really suggestive of the
potential for optical neural networks is
that we managed to show mnist
handwritten digital classification
using less than a single photon per
scalar multiplication
so that's this red highlighted box here
is really the highlight of this figure
you're showing the accuracy of imminent
digit classification as a function of
how many photons were used in the
processor
and
at first glance this might seem a little
crazy if how can you perform a
multiplication using less than a photon
how do you even encode the information
less than a photon and essentially the
the trick is that
you're performing vector vector of
products where you're summing over many
scalar multiplications and so you have a
lot of noise when you use this few
photons per multiplication
but when you sum over many of them the
noise gets averaged down and so overall
this ends up working
and if we look towards the future we and
others have been doing projections of uh
how big would you have to make an
optical neural network to actually out
compete a gpu or a tpu or some other
cmos device
and it turns out that in the case of for
example transformer models
for language
natural language processing
there is a crossover point and
there's
certainly sort of reasonable size models
where you can imagine getting several
orders of magnitude
energy efficiency improvements even when
you bake in the costs of not just the
photons but all the electronic
infrastructure around the optical neural
network itself like you have detectors
that are electronic they have to have
adcs and there's dax and so on
but even when you account for all of
that if you make the system big enough
uh you can really
uh foresee a future where you get an
energy advantage and the reason for this
is
maybe a little bit glibly that
optical neural networks have the
potential to do n squared operations uh
in optics where you only have to pay an
order in energy cost to get the data in
and out
and so if you make
you have a lot of constant factors but
if you make things big enough the n
the n squared in electronics ends up
dominating and the n and optics-based
systems can uh can end up if even in
kind of absolute terms end up winning in
energy efficiency so i think this is a
very interesting direction um and
uh there's a lot of people working on
this and this uh general approach of
trying to take a complex optical system
and and get it to do machine learning
for you i think is
is going to be something that we
we in my group play with a lot over the
next couple of years
another direction that
is
somewhat related the previous slide but
is more general is the notion of smart
senses and so an example of this is in
it's inspired by
kind of human systems is that if you
think about the optical bandwidth going
into
like the data rate going into the human
eye
at least i didn't calculate this
somebody calculated that this is
apparently about 10 megabits per second
of data um but the human brain is
actually only processing at about 100
bits per second
so what's what's going on well it turns
out that there's some very serious kind
of compression stage that's going on at
the beginning before you get to the
neural network stage if you will
[Music]
and this has inspired
a thought from our side which is if you
have some physical system that you can
train
you can send some physical object or
signal into this physical system and
train that physical system to perform
some transformation for you that
effectively does this kind of
compression from 8.75 megabits per
second down to 100 bits per second and
then you perform some transduction and
adc and digital processing afterwards
so you can use a physical system to
basically do compression for you in some
sense but not a general purpose
compression like a gzip but
neural network compression dedicated
specifically to the task you're trying
to do and so this physical object or
data could be photons like in the case
of human eye but this could also be
fluid flow it could be literal molecules
it could be acoustic waves it could be
mechanical forces and this processing of
this physical system we're imagining
that this is in the same domain so if
we're talking about photons going in
then this physical system should be some
optical system if it's some fluid flow
then this might be some literally some
fluid liquid system if it's acoustic
waves this could be something like our
mechanical plate on a speaker again
and as a concrete example of this we've
recently been working on
doing real scene imaging where we have
some 3d printed car scene with stop
signs and so on
where we send this through a multiple
layers of optical
transformations that we then train
where the goal is to try get the whole
visual scene down into just a few pixels
on a camera
and you've really forced a strong
bottleneck there
and the big benefit of this in principle
is that you can now have the camera go
at much much higher frame rates than
where possible otherwise because if you
insisted on taking a 10 megapixel image
uh you you're going to be stuck to
some number of tens of hertz frame rates
uh maybe a bit higher but you're not
going to get be able to get the
gigahertz but if you
are able to perform optical
pre-processing to get to a point where
you now have only uh let's say four
pixels here now you can run these four
pixels at a gigahertz
uh so this is i think it's a a very nice
example of how kind of doing processing
in the physical domain of the data that
you you got in the first place could
actually give you a practical benefit
and it's something that's not really
comparable to
a gpu or a tpu it couldn't have done
this because you can't just put a gpu in
here before you have your camera the gpu
can only come afterwards
so another uh
future direction that i think is
really interesting and ties a lot with
my background of in in quantum computing
is you know quantum physical neural
networks so there are many people
interested in quantum neural networks
and you can see this goes back to at
least the early 90s of people proposing
quantum versions of neural networks but
there's been a renaissance of this over
the last five or so years this is just
paper from 2018 is just one of many
examples of neural network papers that
people have proposed on a quantum
computer running a series of quantum
gates where the gates are parameterized
by some angles for example and these are
the tunable parameters of your neural
network and you fiddle with the angles
and the quantum circuits such that you
train the circuit to give an output that
it says an eight when you put in an
eight an image of an eight and so on
uh and this has been generalized to
uh sort of quantum circuit learning
where you can imagine generic circuits
of
quantum circuit where you have some
input encoding and then some
programmable unitary that has
programmable parameters that you train
to to perform whatever task you want
and the the kind of key thing of all
these things that have come up in the
last or almost all of the literature in
the space that's come up over the last
few years people want
to use to do this on standard circuit
model quantum computers like google and
ibm and others are building but our
thought is to follow is what if we adapt
our procedure that uh
that i showed earlier for classical
systems and instead now of a physical
system that is some very
weird classical system like a shaken
piece of metal what if we now instead of
putting a instead of using a quantum
computer we take some quantum system
that is not well calibrated it's
dissipative potentially
um it's definitely not on its own a
quantum computer but it's still a system
that behaves according to the laws of
quantum mechanics and is not trivially
classical
can we somehow turn that into a useful
quantum neural network and i think if we
use this procedure we should be able to
and in this case well what would the
differentiable digital model be how
would we do that
well if the system's big enough you'll
probably need to actually use a standard
circuit model quantum computer to do
this um
so we think this is an interesting
direction as well can we turn badly
designed quantum systems into useful
neural networks potentially using
standard quantum computers for doing the
training
and then a final direction that i wanted
to mention was
beyond machine learning what could this
be good for in some strong sense
physics aware training is letting us
train a physical piece of hardware to
perform a particular function and the
function we're choosing is essentially
the
the feed-forward function of a neural
network but it doesn't have to be that
so
as an example imagine we want to perform
we want to make a filter and we want to
perform some filter function
and the conventional approach to doing
this would be you define your filter and
you say well this is this is the cutoff
frequency i want and
this is the 3db bandwidth and so on this
is the center frequency
and a circuit designer goes off and uses
the known building blocks and filter
design theory and simulations and so on
to design some cmos circuit that will do
this
but using the physical neural networks
and physics aware training approach you
can imagine doing this in a completely
different way which is that you can take
some material or device that has tunable
parameters and you can train those
parameters such that the material or
device performs this input output map
that you
you wanted from whatever you designed
which could have been a filter
and so what are some materials or
devices you might do this with one of
the things that we're actually playing
with is
networks of oscillators you if you
imagine having a bunch of oscillators
that are coupled in some tunable way
uh and these are non-linear oscillators
and you can you can program how strongly
they're coupled to one another you can
imagine
tweaking these parameters such that
given whatever rf input signal you put
into one of the oscillators you can make
the rf output signal
maybe not anything you want but some
large
set of possible functions can be applied
to it
and this could also be
some some more exotic thing like a
quantum material that you could maybe
have source and gate and drain voltages
on and that you could fiddle
fiddle with the parameters of voltages
applied to the material and see what
input output relations is able to
represent
so with that i will
put up a summary so basically i've shown
how we can use
a training procedure that we've designed
physics away training to harness
the computation the physical systems
naturally do to perform machine learning
for us and we've demonstrated this
procedure with three different types of
system a mechanical one an electrical
one and an optical one
and we've shown it on a relatively
simple task of amnesty classification
but hopefully that proof of principle is
inspirational about what else we could
do with this
and i think there are many interesting
future directions to take this line of
work including trying to figure out how
to scale to large large scale devices
that could potentially actually beat
cmos processors but as well as things
where we're not directly competing with
gpus for example in smart sensors or
building quantum physical neural
networks out of systems that are not
well designed quantum computers as well
as
trying to endow
uh
materials and devices with new
functionality that they didn't otherwise
have
uh so with that i'll leave it there and
i'm very happy to to stick around with
questions but thank you very much for
your attention and for the question so
far and again the invitation to speak
uh did you try to use an optical device
with some kind of controllable shadow
on the picture
the reason for that because i'm
surprised your first experiments about
when you feed the picture through linear
row it get some uh positive results with
very good accuracy
uh
usually uh neural networks actually has
a
need to have a close relationship
adjusting pixels
to make a good recognition because when
pixels are located far away it's where
influence through system need to you
need to have many many layers to get
that influence right
so in case of optical it's much easier
because you have a
regular optic or regular picture
and you may try to make a matrix of
controllable shadow as a
as a
vectors for collection
for training
right so in the
examples that i showed
over
here
i think in the end for each of these
ones
we ended up doing things with patches
because like you said if you just
flatten the neural network into 1d
um
[Music]
it will work but it won't work very well
i think to get the results that we
showed here we did the slightly more
sophisticated thing of of sort of
flattening into patches so that you
preserve some of the locality
um
in the case and in in all three examples
including the optical case here we were
going from 2d into 1d because the
encoding in the optics case was in the
frequency domain which only has one
dimension
but
in the case of this other work that
we've done
on optical neural networks you literally
do feed just the image into the system
and it makes multiple copies of it and
then
you could perform these uh the weight
multiplications in element element wise
fashion but here we're not flattening
into 1d and this is indeed a place where
you could imagine putting a mask in
front of the image over here for example
to
essentially i guess it identifies
features in some sense
um
that's not something we've done but uh i
agree it's something that a principal
one could do
what we've done is uh
is do this in multiple layers we
achieved these results this was with
mnist we did three layers of the neural
network and it was possible to achieve
reasonable accuracy um with three layers
so we didn't need to play any extra
tricks but indeed we did have to have
multiple layers to get it to work
because with just one layer it wouldn't
it wouldn't be able to achieve this
accuracy at least
you probably need to also to think about
loops
in regular
neural networks models right now it's
very popular to have
uh some uh bypass of information and
that's a reason to get a influence
uh
mixing
mixing information from first layer to
later layers
that's right these skip connections are
very common in a number of different
architectures so i guess the two things
i can say about that one is that
there's some sense in which the
continuous time dynamical systems are
intrinsically doing this this is this
really nice proof from wine and e and
others uh showing that a continuous time
system at least some particular
continuous time system you can really
think about it as doing this this
discrete neural network that has the
skips um that's maybe a little bit too
glib though i think we have
we haven't in
this work demonstrated ones where we put
skip connections in but in principle we
could
um there's nothing stopping us from from
programming and skip connections either
physically or in a laptop
the other thing i could say is that
we'd be very interested in transformers
and the transformer models are um where
is it over here
ones where there's less of the skip
connection business which is maybe a
little bit more natural for optics where
you really want to
at least if you're trying to do
everything as up with as much optics and
as little electronics as possible it's
it's helpful to avoid the skips but uh
it's it's still possible to do it as
long as if you're going into electronics
afterwards uh before the next layer you
can store things in a little bit of
electronic memory and and be able to
kind of
yeah
introduce the skip in the in the laptop
thank you
yeah uh so uh one more question about
the e-coding i'm very interested in that
sorry yeah uh
so uh
how many different
just curious how many different kind of
encodings just right because i wonder if
you have ever tried a space building
curve like a fractal and i i wonder if
the if that would do anything to
to the performance
that's an interesting question i don't
think we've tried any
any fractal one it's an interesting
thought though
uh yeah it it might be better we should
give it a go yeah because it sounds like
a fractal preservative or locality kind
of like different different scales right
because you have that curious furious
characteristic
right
yeah
okay yeah
so that's an interesting suggestion i i
i don't really have much to say other
than we should probably give it a try
because i it's possible that like like i
said at the start i'm not the one who
personally does the work but i don't
remember the postdocs of students
telling me about them trying that so
probably we haven't either that or my
memory is bad or both
okay thank you yeah and uh i have
another question
so uh
do you think is it it's possible to so
so the example you are currently giving
you are computing like either over a
fixed size vector or you are just
computing a stream of like a stream of
scalar value or
or like again like a vector value over
time it i wonder if
is it possible to compute on
the normal of the data structure in the
normal sense in computer science which
which are maybe graph or trees and they
are highly irregular and they might be
they
and they might have a like much bigger
size than the
than the internal state vector of your
physical system because
if i'm going to uh so if
you think about a
analogy
currently is it at least the examples
i'm seeing it seems that it is like
computing with a registered machine and
with without only a fixed number of
registers
with that and without and like an
external memory and i wonder
if
if there's an analog of a
of a random access machine
to to this like physical computing
system
right yeah that's a very interesting set
of points
um so the first thing i should say is in
all three three examples we're using
fixed size essentially arrays or vectors
that we're feeding into the system
um and in principle you can make
something that actually works on
streaming data and we've thought a
little bit about this and
we haven't yet published any experiments
on it but we've we've certainly done
some simulations and thought about it of
what about designing some
dynamical system where you continuously
feed time series into it and it just it
never ends and it keeps continually
performing some tasks on that and that's
also possible
um
the point about
memory is very astute
this
these physical systems currently we're
kind of limited in how much data we can
put into them both data data and
parameters um because they don't have
directly connected to them some memory
we just have a computer with some memory
and then we're feeding it in via
essentially
some transducer
and
that is a pretty severe limitation on
scaling these to really large sizes so
one of the things we're really trying to
push towards when you go to for example
an optical neural network is thinking
how can you make this thing as big as
possible
um and in optics it turns out that it
seems pretty reasonable to go pretty big
why because
we can have a
like a 10 10 megapixel image that we
project onto some crystal so we're going
to get at least
10 million data points in every time we
can flash that image on
there's still
a bunch of
tricky business though because well you
can do that at maybe 10 hertz but what
about if you want to go to gigahertz
so you need to try to be
a little careful with things that it's
very analogous to things that are
happening in the cmos neural network
accelerator community because they have
a very similar problem of
neural networks work better and better
if you have more and more parameters you
want to have as many parameters as
possible they can't necessarily all stay
within the on-chip memory and it's very
expensive to move things on and off
the chip so what do you do well you try
to design things where you reuse the
weights as much as possible and
in the case of optics you try to fan out
the data optically which is free in
optics but not in electronics
but it's a pretty difficult systems
engineering challenge because you
at least in a physical system you don't
naturally have a memory so you you have
to somehow
find a way to take advantage of things
either being static or taking advantage
of memories that are outside the system
and another final thought on that is
there's some physical systems where you
can imagine the physical system itself
having memory like you
shine light on a crystal and it heats
part of it up so it sort of remembers
what happened before and i think it's a
very interesting direction to try and
figure out how to harness that we don't
exactly know how to use that to our
benefit yet but it seems in principle
like this kind of thing where physical
systems have a memory of what happened
to them
could be useful beyond just building a
recurring neural network you want memory
because we know how to do that but to do
it in the sense you're talking about uh
probably requires more work
i see thank you yeah very inspiring this
is a great great question so thank you
uh i have a question uh i wonder how uh
how's the system um behave when the in
the presence of maybe noise or device
mismatches because i i'm
i think there must be some like you know
uh non-ideality happen inside those
mechanical systems or optic systems or
or either electronic system i wonder
like how large does it affect the
training accuracy maybe like does the
training accuracy the same every time
you run the with the same parameters
or or does the noise like affect the the
results yeah that's a great question so
essentially the biggest challenge we had
in this project was trying to deal with
making a training procedure that was
resilient to the noise because
the model inaccuracy slash the noise you
have
really destroys things if you only train
on the laptop which is what was shown in
the black here you trade on the laptop
the laptop tells yeah trained it great
you should get 90 accuracy and then you
run it on the actual physical hardware
and you get no answers no better than
random guessing and this is because the
model
in the laptop was different than the
physical thing and so it went the model
and laptop went off into some weird part
of parameter space where it said this
should be giving you a good answer and
you run a little harder and it's
actually different
um and so that was really what motivated
us to do this loop where we have the
physical hardware in the loop and then
it turns out to be pretty good and you
can wonder then why is this succeeding
why is this resilient to noise and it's
one of the intuitions is that because
during the training procedure it's
subject to the noise
it more or less learns to not go into
parts of parameter space that are very
sensitive to the noise because if you do
that then
you'll get bad you'll get bad errors
so the this procedure is robust there is
a catch which is once you've done the
training
and you now have your parameters if your
physical system changes
and you then try run again you're not
going to get good results so these
results some of these took a few days to
collect
so these physical systems were like the
training procedure was robust to the
variation you have over days now
if we try
do it again
on some of these uh especially the
the optics one i think like a year later
it's probably not going to be very good
the mechanics one actually
this can be
can be revived pretty easily so this one
actually stays
stays the same for
at least months
but uh it depends on the physical system
because you do need you do require that
like
the
the physical system perform roughly the
same function between when you trained
it and when you want to use it
i see yeah that makes sense like yeah in
the training kind of explicitly consider
the noise in the learning process right
and another cool interpretation of
what's going on here is why does this
work when the model isn't exactly right
is that
the gradient only has to be in the right
direction if the gradient is in the
correct direction for each value in the
parameters
then it will make progress
if the if the model was so inaccurate
versus the physical system itself that
the gradients were coming out to be the
wrong direction then you would not be
able to train because it would never go
it would never it would never move in
the right direction but so long as the
model is close enough to the physical
system that the gradients or to have the
right sign then it makes progress and we
quantified how inaccurate the model can
be and have those things still work and
it turns out that you can have model
misspecification mismatch of
tens of percent and it's still it still
is okay
i see then we expect that if if if we're
going to move this uh methodology to
sensor smart sensor well do you think it
will like become worse because i would
imagine for example for optic systems
like
in in your normal training scheme you're
going to provide like lasers but if you
put it on the sensors those lights are
become more like less like the noise
right inside of those uh
uh lights become like
a larger portion of that
i would right
yes
i think always with these going to be a
trade-off of how much robustness you
want to the system and how long you want
it to last and so on versus how much
energy efficiency you want it to have so
in our work on smart sensors
for imaging uh we've just we've we
haven't taken some completely random
optical system and tried to use that we
tried to engineer an optical system that
would be relatively stable
and not use it with light that was super
sensitive to a lot of parameters but we
paid a a price an engineering price in
that of now our system won't be as
energy efficient
uh or as low cost as it could it could
have been so i think there's always
going to be with these a trade-off if
you take literally a shaken piece of
metal it's sort of like the minimum cost
but
it's maybe not as robust as if you
carefully design it and there's always
you need to pick where you want to be in
that continuum like another example
would be sort of a
cmos layout versus
randomly scattered transistors um
those are the two extremes but you can
imagine kind of things in the middle
where you're uh
where you're
getting more benefit but now you're
insisting on
uh on more
or if you want more robustness you have
to lose a little bit in the energy
efficiency
i see yeah that that makes sense yeah we
always need to do some trade-offs like
for energy and accuracy yeah thanks
sure another concrete example of that is
like
in in this work here we were doing pixel
the pixel mapping where literally one
pixel is going through one pixel going
to one pixel tnu did an amazing job
aligning more than 500 000 pixels to be
exactly matched with each other but it
turns out that
yeah that's pretty hard to do but you
can imagine making a system that's more
dense and more energy efficient if you
don't insist on doing that now you try
kind of compensate for the aberrations
that happened
uh in principle you could use the pit
strategy to try compensate for things
and but the benefits you get is now the
system can be smaller
i see yeah thanks thanks for
for the explanation
well if enough further questions uh i'd
like to thank everyone again for well
all the questions i do received so far
and uh and for your attention
throughout the talk thank you very much
well thank you very much it's been a
great talk
awesome thanks very much appreciate the
invitation really great uh
piece of work and uh it's gonna see
practical application all over
everywhere i think
i'm hopeful we'll
we'll see at least academic application
and if we're really lucky practical
application i'll be very excited if it
makes it into the real world
okay
any case thank you very much for the
talk and we'll be in touch awesome
thanks so much dennis appreciate it
thanks everyone bye